hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game that was played in the
Pro-Am open uh it was sent to me by
David Lada a true appreciator of great
games so I am thankful that he sent me
this one it's a game between uh Peruvian
International master or rather women
Grandmaster Daisy Corey and a Spanish
Grandmaster David larino Nieto and it's
I mean such a a brutal game at the black
king the the mileage the the black king
does in this game is just incredible uh
you guys will enjoy it let's let's dive
straight into it and see uh what
happened here because from the thumbnail
you you know that something weird is
happening in this one so Daisy has the
white pieces and she opens with Pond G3
she goes for the king spin key at the
opening and we have Pawn to D5 a very
principled way of dealing with um uh the
the the the
opening with Ponte G3 you want to grab
hold of the center upon the G2 and now
Pawn to E5 sorry about that uh
grabbing hold of the full Center C4 now
challenging the center and now Pawn to
D4 advancing the pawn with E3
challenging the D4 Pawn Knight to C6 in
the Now Pawn to A3 uh there are some
games for ecatra some D4 was played also
Knights the E2 is an on move but Pawn to
A3 is a new move so already as of move 5
we have a completely new game so of
course we have Pawn to A5 stopping B4 we
have D3 and now D captures an E3 with
Bishop captures and E3 and Knight to G7
Knight to C3 just nicely continuing
development and now Knight the F5
putting pressure on the bishop and E3
and just Knight to D5 so how do you
continue do you capture the bishop do
you do you go for development where uh
here interestingly David goes for Knight
to D4 and now uh how do you how do you
react to this it's a very annoying night
the night covers the C2 Square D to
square df3 square the B3 Square so you
do not want it there but you don't want
to play something like the bishop
captures on D4 the Knight captures the
other night takes its place and you
don't have a c Pawn or an E Pawn to get
rid of it so instead after this ignites
the D4 move we have Bishop to G5
attacking the black queen and it seems
like F6 is impossible because there's
always that Queen to H5 a very nasty
idea
the problem is here it's the absolute
best move and it's the absolute best
reply for white to capture on F6 and
that's exactly what happens here Bishop
captures an F6 G captures and now Queen
to H5 there is no G Pawn to prevent the
check so King to D7 the Knight and queen
are covering E7 and F7 so the King has
to start running and now look at this
King to D7 we have Queen the F7 check
and now King to C6 it seems like you
could block with some like Bishop to A7
but this just runs into a beautiful mate
into Knight captures an F6 check King to
D6 and now Queen to D5 will be Checkmate
so you can't block uh with the Knight or
with the bishop for that matter it's the
exact same Checkmate so after Queen to
F7 check we have King the C6 and now the
problem is how do you how do you finish
this it it just seems like it shouldn't
be possible to have your King on C6 with
a queen and F7 with the Knight on D5 and
with all sorts of nasty discoveries
threatening at the Jack made that King
the problem is as soon as the Knight
moves and you deliver this check you
have King the B6 and once King the B6
Lance you have King to A7 and then the
king hides and white is down material
for the moment even if you try something
like Knight captures on C7 with check
now the bachelor delivers check the
queen defends the Knight but King B6 and
even if you capture The Rook with check
there is King to A7 now attacking the
Knight and now uh how do you how do you
continue this there there's just no good
way of doing it if you go Rook to C1
because uh you always have to keep in
mind that Knight the C2 check will win
the Rook on A1 and this is now even
though the black king is running for his
life it's a game of material Rook to C1
for example King captures an A8 and now
uh black is just that material it's it's
uh it's a nice position you could play
something like C5 for example King B8 on
pinning from the B Pawn uh Pawn to C6
let's say captures and now continuing
Knight to F3 and okay it's a game but uh
with uh with uh you know some some
reasonably good play but will be able to
win this so instead after King the C6
how do you how do you continue the
attack well Daisy finds C5 and it's a
it's a very nice idea it covers the B6
square and now once the Knight moves the
king will not have King to B6 and if you
try something like Bishop captures on C5
uh well then Knight captures on C7 uh is
it is a bit different because now you
can't really go to B6 if B6 Knight
captures an eight would check King to A7
and Rook 8 to C1 now comes with Tempo so
you will not be down too much material
so that's not really the way to go so
instead after this C5 move uh we have a
knight to C2 with check this is the
absolute best move by David uh King to
D2 and not Knight captures on A1 we have
Knight captures on C7 with check now the
B6 square is covered so King captures on
C5 the King goes deeper into White's
position and now how do you keep the
king not going the B6 and A7 is it
possible well Queen to C4 check is one
option but it's hard to continue because
after King to B6 there is no way to
finish the attack there's just uh and
not much you can do and even if you go
King to D6 it's still not great you can
play Knight captures on A8 okay grab the
Rook now Bishop H6 with check and after
King D1 Bishop T6 and you're just up too
much uh material again there's no attack
Happening Here the queen is hanging the
Knight is hanging and there is no way to
continue so after King captures on C5
Knights the E2 is played now the other
Rook can join the attack but now we have
King the V6 the move white was unable to
stop Rook to C1 defending the Knight on
C7 and now Knight to D6 attacking the
White Queen and now uh Queen all the way
back to A2 another interesting idea was
just Queen to D5 this is very nice as it
does threaten Queen to C5 with the
Checkmate the problem is black is more
than happy to give up the queen Queen
captures on C7 will captures King
captures and the black is just up way
too much material so instead Queen to 80
was played now okay if you if you give
up the queen at least in the end of the
line the queen will be able to take the
Knight on it on A1 so maybe you can
still fight but now Bishop to H6 with
check Pawn to F4 and now Bishop to G4
uh pretty much developing everything uh
and the white is uh White is out of
ideas here again you could go after the
the A8 Rook but that just doesn't work
in any of the lines that we've shown
King to A7 and now what do you what do
you play here if Queen captures on A1 or
something there's e captures on F4 now
this is being threatened this is being
threatened the the the the king is still
in the middle of the board uh there's no
way for white to actually attack so
instead Queen back to D5 now deciding uh
to threaten this queen to C5 Checkmate
but not just Queen captures on C7 giving
up the queen Rook captures on C7 King
captures on C7 and now Knight to C3 so
it's a queen Knight and Bishop versus
two Rooks two Bishops and two knights e
captures an F4 now threatening a
discovery here Knight the B5 with check
uh with the idea of eliminating the
defender of the B7 Pawn so Knight
captures on B5 interestingly this is the
only uh move that that um uh gains
Advantage for black so Queen captures on
B7 with check King to D6 now Queen to B6
check King to E7 and now Bishop captures
an A8 grabbing that Rook F captures on
G3 opening up a discovery and now King
to E1 and now look at this a very very
unpleasant Pawn covers the F2 Square
Bishop cover Z to square the outer
Bishop covers the D2 Square uh Knight
the C2 with check and also the D1 square
is covered by the Light Square Bishop so
you have to play King to F1 so King to
F1 and now even Rook captures an A8
giving up the Rook uh Queen to B7 with
check Bishop to D7 now and queen
captures an A8 with check and now comes
Bishop to H3 with check and it was in
this position unmove 31 that Daisy Corey
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here we've reached the
position from the thumbnail and this is
where she resigned this is covered by
the bishop this is covered by the pawn
this is covered by the Knight so your
only options crr King G1 and the King to
E2 if you go King to E2 it's just
another uh a mating sequence Knight beta
D4 check King to D1 and now Bishop to G4
checked the only move is Queen to F3 and
once you block Bishop captures it will
be Checkmate and another thing you can
do after Bishop to H through to check is
go to G1 but this is not much better
just Bishop to E3 with check King to H1
and G2 check and now there are no more
moves only move is to give up the queen
but once you do that captures captures
and captures now uh black is just up two
knights and uh and the bishop and David
of course we will have no no problem
converting this uh so yeah after Bishop
page three Daisy resigned and what what
a spectacular game a wonderful wonderful
attacking sequence and it's just uh now
in the era of modern chess especially
with these spectacular young players
like like ukesh Arjun and um uh you know
the uh all those vacancies it was
Pakistan players uh it's uh remarkable
what kind of uh well disgusting engine
lines they can play and just get away
with everything and this is uh well this
also reminded me of that I mean it's so
incredible that the king can't survive
on C6 I mean this is uh this looks like
a diagram you know if someone were to
give it to you and and you know like
white the mate in six or white the mate
in three uh but no actually white has to
play uh you know
absolutely precise moves to to maybe
maybe hope uh to to save this game
because black is just is just better
here
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it very nicely played by
both of them now David was able to take
this one uh but what a game it was so
really hope you enjoyed it I would like
to wish a very happy birthday to dhanush
and I would like to wish a very happy
birthday to pedrino and I would like to
thank Lord of Chess Anderson Vera and
torko stanquist for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one this one
came from David Landa uh who really
knows how to spot a nice one so uh
hopefully we we receive more in the
future uh and you know whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day